tonight on Kitchen Nightmares Gordon
goes to Ridgewood New Jersey to meet the
most defensive Chef he's ever met Paul
bazini I don't have all the tickets
memorized not only is the restaurant
failing I don't want to get out of bed
in the morning I'm miserable but a
staffer fed up with his Tantrums that's
why you have a ticket don't push it Paul
but what's with the [__] sarcasm what
the [__] you want for me his wife is fed
up with his attitude never saw anything
like that my wife think that I like this
I don't I have nothing else to say to
you and the customers are fed up with
not being fed get my food now and every
time something goes wrong we're sinking
like the Titanic in here all Paul wants
to do I can't do everything myself is
give excuse don't have eyes in the back
of my head after excuse I'm doing 400
things at once after excuse I can't cook
and talk and manage the tickets I need
help
stop you have given up will Chef ramsy
be able to finally get through to him
have some fire in your belly or will
Paul finally run out of excuses I know
that it starts and stops with me you say
all the right things find out tonight on
Kitchen Nightmares now it's time to do
the right
things Bridgewood New Jersey an affluent
suburb well known for the sheer volume
of restaurants smack in the middle of
this Pleasant town is a 5-year-old
restaurant run by a former Manhattan
star Chef Paul bazini I'm a very good
Chef we got a full dining room drop
another pan for four more here we go
I've always been in the industry and
worked my way up and became executive
chef and worked in many places in
Manhattan that had a lot of notoriety I
love you love you too Paul has been
recognized many times throughout his
career he has has been written up in
several magazines with some very
positive reviews and I absolutely
thought the restaurant was going to be a
success but Paul never anticipated the
transition from Star Chef to owner would
be so difficult I don't have any Focus e
days is I wake up in the morning and I
say what direction should I go in today
should I cook should I shop should I
work in the front of the house should I
work on marketing should I pay bills and
it's like overwhelming killing me I
think the pressure of owning the
restaurant has definitely beat him down
and his pass for food is not burning as
brightly as it once was clearly what's
going on with me in the kitchen is
suffering there's your salad what salad
what table I'm confused I'm confused
yeah New York shft New York sh new okay
you're right I am distracted I am
frustrated I'm angry always somebody
always somebody always somebody and then
I'm frustrated with the food and I'm
slamming plates down cuz the plate
doesn't look the way that I want it to
look it's messy but let's just go with
it okay the resulta was burnt I don't
know is it supposed to be spicy L
complaints yeah so I heard I don't feel
like me I feel like somebody else I feel
like me looking at somebody
else everyone knows that he's just not
good about criticism this needs to be
heated up these are perfect okay he gets
pissed off and he yells I don't have all
the tickets memorized why well that's
why you have a ticket yeah okay do you
think if you had a lot of money you
wouldn't be so goddamn
Moody I support the restaurant
financially certainly if I didn't do
that we would have been bankrupt years
ago there's no magic ATM machine like in
the backyard like a Magic Money Tree
that I can just go pick money from there
are no college funds for our children
every day I'm scared that we're not
going to be able to pay the bills we
need help we need direction we need
advice my resume and all my accolades
don't mean a hill of beans if I can't
make it work here his passion for
cooking defines him and I feel like it's
lost to him right now he needs to get it
back
[Music]
there are over 60 restaurants within
four blocks inside this beautiful town
now after seeing a few of them my mouth
is watering I can't wait for lunch right
bazis inovative American
[Music]
Cuisine
what no am I too late bazine is ours
Monday to Thursday 5: till
9:30 [__] no lunch that's ridiculous my
B Gordon ha where are you call
[Music]
me
unbelievable hello hi may speak to Chef
Ramsey please is that Paul hi this is
this is Paul bazini how are you sorry I
missed you I didn't realize you closed
for lunch uh yes sir we're closed for
lunch okay I'm on my
[Music]
way I'm
starving how are you hi welcome to
bazini Chef Ramsey pleasure to meet you
Gordon Gordon Paul pleasure to meet you
nice to see you too wow this is minute
isn't it it's challenging my goodness me
is this it yes sir wow it's like being
inside a doll's house it's uh some Decor
challenges here well you're here yes sir
finally I'm here okay um clearly there's
nothing else going on lunch wise why
don't you cook me something okay don't
show me the menu you decide okay yeah
yeah I have to just you know focus on
like the food will it be to his taste
will it be to his opinion who
knows this place makes me feel nervous
it's small it's cramped and no wanted
the clothes for lunch God so narrow look
at this place place from one table to
the next
[Music]
huh God they
grimy oh [__] that's
[Music]
depressing Entre comes with sound
effects maybe he'll blow me away with
the food because the
atmosphere my God it's
[Music]
depressing I'm thinking that I want to
send out just a just a few light dishes
to him something hot something cold
something grilled something sauteed just
a full rounded experience hey Paul I'm
here to help hey how's it going how you
got good I think Chef Ramsay is going to
have a lot of things to say to Paul
about how to change things and I don't
think Paul's going to take it well
gentleman said he was very hungry so
fair enough I think Paul has his own
ideas that what he's doing is just right
it doesn't need to be changed and uh I
think some of those things do need to be
changed here we go that is the fetuccini
mhm basil rugal aesto little orot Salada
on top much and then behind that here is
a chicken Payard sort of millanes
pounded breaded excellent I didn't catch
your name my name's Alex Alex Charmed
good to see you so much pleasure I'll be
back in a moment thank you
Alex
cold Bland reallyy Bland okay look at
this thing it's like a [__]
elephant's
foot m
[Music]
that's not normal for a chicken to be so
[__]
hot
[Music]
F that's a mess thank you Alex
absolutely and I'd appreciate if the
chef could actually taste that okay cuz
it is Bland Beyond Bland okay um why is
that so dry H I wish I had a good answer
for that question chicken should be
moist well I'll move straight to the
next course thank
sure fetuccini plant chicken why is it
so dry that's
[__] I want to go home Paul
certainly doesn't like it when people
criticize his food but I you know I
think he actually reacted to Chef
Ramsey's criticisms the same way he
reacts to a lot of the guest's
criticisms like maybe it's not
necessarily that important cuz he's
right hello hello how are you very well
I'm Leslie bini nice to see you D nice
to see you thank you for coming we
really appreciate your help it means a
lot to us that you're here I don't want
to get emotional but thank you very
happy to be here and uh can I give you a
hug of course you can have a hug there
we are feel better here is someone who
has the ability to help us and um he's
going to you know that's a
miracle okay great well I'm going to
finish my uh lunch yes absolutely thank
you thank you thank you Hi H hello
lovely thank you here we are okay that
is our mushroom from Roto mhm thank
you damn is that
normal amazing bazini risotto woo wow
that's extraordinary now doesn't even
move well maybe that look better
there
yeah it fits the colors come
on
go what a mess an absolutely disgusting
so you don't look too impressed I just
Taste of mush thank you my pleasure I'll
bring you some tilapia
next nah he doesn't like that he doesn't
like it too mushy there is a classic you
know way to do it but some people around
here just don't like it that way you
know my ego is not here to hear that
Gordon Ramsay loved the dishes or didn't
like the dishes I'm not concerned about
that I'm concerned about what I do how
what the product that that I put out
it's all yours Alex all right here we go
almond crusted tilapia jasmine rice with
some pepper hopefully you enjoy it
[Music]
wow I love the jasmine rice he has to
like the jasmine
rice it's just so Bland honestly I mean
it's just greasy Bland and you cut into
the fish and it's just mush how's the
tilapia coming along we making some
forward progress here yeah no I'm do you
know what I'm uh
I'm still hungry um do you have
something in mind any desserts certainly
Sharon or dessert Chef makes everything
I've got a carry cake oh wow should be a
New York cheesecake do you know I have a
little Slice of Cheesecake and the
carrot cake done
please yes cheesecake carrot cake
tilapia no go fish was Bland watery fish
was Bland again which we're kind of like
we have a older clientele here they like
not too assertive things right how could
I think that Paul did a good job you
know if he did a good job Chef Ram he
would have said the food was great you
know he didn't say that so Paul didn't
do a good job we start right here with a
carrot cake wow all homemade yes
absolutely thank
you hi Gordon's eating your carrot cake
right now as we
[Music]
speak oh the last thing that people eat
is dessert and if the dessert sucks
that's
bad hey bloody do you scared me don't
come around the corner like that
Sharon Sharon first of all that is
delicious awesome now whose recipe is
that mine can I have it if for a price
everything a price I'm glad you said
that that's made with passion as much as
you have you make love to that carrot
cake don't you well I'm getting divorc
so it's the cake or uh I'll go for the
cake hope he likes some sh it's going to
be devastated if he hates it I hate it
I'm so glad you liked it honestly I
thought like it's a [__] wak in a
funeral and all of a sudden the carrot
cakes arrive and wof I'm back up there I
love
you although dessert left Chef Ramsey
with a good taste in his mouth it still
doesn't erase the bad taste of the rest
of the meal let's talk about the food
dessert let's go backwards okay yeah
that was delicious good glad you enjoy
it really good
um great way to finish clearly but I
certainly didn't start off like
that I said to you show me your best
give it to me big time the risoto was in
embarrassing PA it tasted the way it
looked damn is that normal Bland mushy
and it looked atrocious honestly it was
[__] disgusting the chicken how many
days were you baking that for seriously
I mean you may laugh but it's not funny
honestly I thought I'd lost my tooth it
was so crunchy on the
outside Dry in the middle it wasn't
intended to be dry or to be overcooked
uh you sent it out I know that that's
the way you normally cook it overdone
certainly don't think that I cook food
overdone okay I me rotto overcooked
chicken overcooked you certainly did for
me okay I I need to get some fresh air
I'm going to come back later I'm here
tonight show it to me okay hopefully
this time with a little bit more effort
okay did you think that he was going to
like
it it angers me that Paul has given up
because I haven't given up you're like
dead I want
the nightmare to be
over coming up a shocking dinner service
where Paul loses control of the kitchen
I don't have all the tickets memorized
and his mind that's why you have a
ticket he ends up taking his frustration
out on his staff what's with the [__]
sarcasm what the [__] you want for me
and on top of that his wife no longer
believes in it never saw anything like
that my life can Chef ramsy make a last
Stitch effort to save Paul have some
fire I'm miserable w
from
himself I never thought in a million
years this could happen that's next on
Kitchen
[Music]
Nightmares this former Manhattan star
Chef failed to impress Chef Ramsey at
lunch now it's time for Chef Ramsey to
see how Paul handles the customers of
Ridgewood New Jersey in a dinner service
all right guys we got to get ready I
hope Paul could get his [__] together
the food is there the capability is
there you just have to do it it's like
you have to [__] or it off the pot hello
good evening can I take your wine
May there you go and this is good to see
you your Su Chef right yes this kitchen
is like a [__] shoe box in here yeah
I know holy crap I think Chef Ramsey
doesn't realize that I worked with a lot
of very well-known chefs it's not
intimidating I have the talent the
desire and I definitely can do the job
crab cake across the board so for this
rard you smell good I smell good after
sh Shan are you hitting on me no I like
the After Shave smells nice oh may just
brush your ass past me no I'm not Gordon
is adorable and of course he's quite the
butt I'm
sorry in the crab cakes ready okay thank
you how come they cooked
already they're pre-
seared you sear a crab cake no we
pre-sear the crab cake and then it goes
into the oven no hold on a minute why
wouldn't you do that to order for to
expedite it out a little bit faster but
surely it'll take longer to get yes
hotter once already cooked yes is it
meal does that not make sense it doesn't
make sense doesn't make
[Music]
sense here is your crab cake sir may I
get you any fresh pepper on that uh no
thank you no how strange how are they
doing in the kitchen a bucket of crab
cakes that just go into the oven to be
reheated but they were s off like
yesterday did you know they were done
there day before of course not I thought
everything was fresh
everything I feel like Paul is losing
his Artistry and that he doesn't care
it's not affecting him it not only pains
me it it angers me quite frankly I mean
that's just not okay it's all burned on
the side I like it's
the F burn is it
really is everything okay with your crab
cakes burn it's over okay let me get
that back here no
problem I need another crab cake on the
Fly what did they say I was burnt Burn
yeah there's two more we're about to go
out please tell me you're not going to
serve them no I'm not Chef we had issues
with the crab cakes tonight it's not the
right way to do it it should be done a
different way and I know how to do it a
different way but that's not how it was
done that it's not it's [__]
disgusting do something about it please
P he's are garbage this is not a
reflection of the way that I want things
to be
okay so how we doing back there right
I'll go check for you it's an hour into
dinner service and very little food has
left the
kitchen around 29 and Bre so hungry in
order to get an accurate picture of the
Slowdown that's not ready there's no
potatoes on honey Chef Ramsey times how
long cook food sits at the
pass
I just think I eat like of bre sitting
here waiting for our food okay 4 minutes
B
steak Paul that's still there yes I'm
working on everything everything is
working hey let me bring some food out
there I yeah but she have her Paul is
communicating but most of his
communication is that he can't handle it
and it's going too fast going to have to
leave yeah J yeah it is a little bit
like a little yeah okay these people are
going to leave if I don't get this one
out he decides how fast things come out
I don't know why it takes so long I just
know it takes so long there has to be S
there
oh okay table 32 can now go thank you
you're welcome finally yes and now after
a long wait those potatoes look a little
over dunge the customers aren't
satisfied okay no problem I'll send that
back for you okay thank you Paul what's
wrong uh it's cold oh come
on I've certainly become annoyed with
clients and I feel like you know people
that want to give you criticism they
just don't know like what you're going
through and if they just knew like a
little bit of what you were going
through they might be a little bit more
compassionate but it's not a
compassionate business is this going
poor I'm just worried about food coming
back cold and this is sat here I was
told that the salads will be ready I'm
waiting for the
salads take half of that salad off what
are you building a [__] Christmas
tree half no half the plates don't look
the way they should when I don't do them
well when I put just take half of the
salad off please follow my directions
I'm going to help you okay I'm not here
to hurt you I'm here to help you
contrary to what everybody says I do
know a few [__] things oh easy to sum
up Paul's moods if he were a woman he
would have PMS 24/7 okay so let me Demo
a chicken Melise for the 400th [__]
time which is nothing more than chicken
and salad and my 12-year-old can [__]
do it yeah listen don't push it Paul
when I don't put it high enough you yell
at me that it's not freaking high enough
why do you have to make it so difficult
for it why can't we why can't why can't
we just finish this chicken millones and
make this particular chicken millones a
right one not talking about yesterday
not talking about next month but what's
with the [__] sarcasm can't but if
you tell me to do it one [__] way
you're changing it what the [__] you
want for me changing it right well you
told me the first [__]
time
why do you have to make it so difficult
for why can't we the battle to get foodo
tonight has resulted in a war in the
kitchen but what what the [__] s what
the [__] you want for me and the impact
is being felt in the dining room get my
food now who's waiting on one 34 has
been waiting for like an hour an hour
this big table behind me what are they
waiting on Whose table is that Julie how
long are you waiting on T over an hour
yeah it's all over an hour this is not
normal surely no tonight is the worst
dinner service that I have ever seen I
mean I have never experienced anything
like this in my
life okay there Paul yes sir I don't
know what's happened but the level of
frustration out there is intense so
stop we can't continue like this stop
it will you apologize the tables please
Rebecca what a freaking disaster bad I
know it was a terrible night we had
people not get food when tickets were
here we failed tonight it's my
responsibility sorry my friends the
kitchen has been shut down I'm so sorry
I've never had to do this
before never saw anything like that in
my life I understand that do you think
that I like this you think that I want
it to be like this I don't but but what
I'm one person with two hands Paul you
don't please don't start with excuses
that's not going to help Paul had a
horrible night 100% off his game and I
think gave up before he even got started
but people hated the food well that's
not what we got back here I'm very angry
saying that someone liked something 50
people didn't like it open your eyes I
have nothing else to say to
you equally as miserable as tonight's
dinner service was Paul's attitude and
Chef Ramsey wants to know why tonight
showed me that you hated cooking I
cannot ignite that little button I need
to see it from you Jeff I feel awful I
this is not the way that I want to work
or the way that I know that I can work
why you doing it to yourself I
I
why you've got to give me the answer
because I can't start helping until you
tell me but I mean no one's asking you
to rent and Rave I'm just asking you to
have some
fire it's not normal for a guy that's
been cooking for 20 years plus to stand
there with no feel or passion and send
[__] like that as if it's just going
over your head whether you like it or
not you have given up
your whole family is on the line here do
you know how hard it is to look at my
kids when I go home at
night or my
wife it's not easy
okay it's not supposed to be easy I
don't care if it's not easy I just want
it to be better but don't stop
[Music]
trying
think I'm happy I'm miserable I don't
want to get out of bed in the morning I
want to stay in
[Music]
bed okay listen I'm committed to helping
you and I'm not leaving this place until
it's set we are going to work at this
together at turning this around tomorrow
I want you at your best yes yes get some
sleep thank you good night good
[Music]
night
after an emotionally draining night Chef
Ramsey has a task in mind to help ignite
Paul's passion in the kitchen good
morning hello um new day new attitude
new start so last night it took us an
hour on average to get appetizers out so
here's what we're doing today I want you
to get used to the time pressure you see
what I'm saying like sort of you know
kickstarting the [__] car again you
know like a new battery in it you got 15
minutes from now to cook me oh God a
stunning pasta dish off you go trying to
kill me you could do it 15 minutes go
Paul in order for Paul to impress Chef
ramsy this Chef is making fresh pasta
for the first time in 5 years I just
want to be able to do what I know how to
do it just you know just cook from the
heart and uh get back to raising the bar
for my myself what are you going to make
I'm just getting a lay of land that's
all you have 14 minutes the clock is
ticking and it's just you know like
everything around me was just turned off
like I wasn't hearing or seeing or
feeling or worrying it was just you know
I was living in the
[Music]
moment 10 minutes babe he's sitting he's
ready he's waiting to be
served you can totally totally wow him
right now please guys watching
everything that he did and I was
definitely afraid that Chef Ramsey
wasn't going to like it and and what
that would mean carry it out I'll carry
it out are you sure you want to do that
yes all
right hey here we go Chef thank you
you're welcome we have a capalini pasta
with a chunky Pesca sauce and some rock
shrimp lovely well I used to be a good
Jeff I think I'm still a good Jeff I
would just want him to be able to
recognize that there was a a passion
that went into making
[Music]
this
Chef Ramsey has put Paul's passion for
cooking to the test we have a capalini
pasta with a Pesca sauce lovely now it's
time to find out if he passed I would
hope that Chef Ramsey would recognize
that you know some love went into making
this dish wipy to his
taste who
knows that's
nice capalini cooked perfectly thank you
it just felt good to just have a really
positive comment from Chef Ram I really
needed that lift what does pasta mean to
you to me it's like bread it's step of
Life mhm pasta can be anything you can
go through all different flavors
textures proteins colors you can have
dried pasta fresh pasta it's a blank
canvas it's you know it's it's just
something for the artist to paint you
sounded more exciting in the last 2
minutes talking about pasta than you
have done since I've met you it was the
old Paul he was excited he was energized
it was the man that I married and it's
really weird isn't it it takes something
like a pasta dish to sort of ignite how
you feel about it absolutely today at
this moment I know that like the healing
process has
begun after a small glimmer of hope this
morning Chef Ramsey wants to try an
experiment time for some sophisticated
marketing he wants to take advantage of
the Ridgewood foot traffic and tests
Paul's speed in the kitchen how are you
so for the first time in 4 years bazini
is open for lunch having lunch today
fabulous lunch menu around the corner
bazini $15 soup salad and the most
amazing pasta wonderful thank you so
much thank you now Chef Ramsey only has
one thing left to do tell the owners so
here's what we're doing today we're
going to serve the most amazing two
course
lunch that's right this is not a formal
long- winded 3-hour ordeal this is a
really nice easy quick vibrant lunch I'm
nervous but you know this is what we're
going to do today fantastic you know
great you know terrific you and I in the
kitchen great I'm your suf okay
fantastic I'm your [__] okay ladies
you've both got great personalities so
both of you running the front of house I
don't know anything about the front of
the house I don't care about the front
of the house I just want to do my job
great service great food in and
out hello
welcome uh follow me please Chef Ramsey
is hoping today's lunch will show Paul
and lesle the opportunity they are not
taking advantage of don't have this
pasta the fantina pasta and the power of
serving fresh pasta soup three
pantanella 2 okay good let's
go two soups are going in the window
Chef to go up with two salads salads 30
seconds P very good thank you don't
forget speed today yes y order in one
soup two oricat two pan an a three
vegetable oricat three regular or very
good waitressing is totally not my thing
I'll be right right with you folks you
girls okay we're just waiting on our
wine um garlic oh my Pen's not writing
I'm sorry Sharon and I are not servers
we did the best that we could is
everything okay we spoons too oh yes I'm
sorry but we forgot that you need a
spoon to eat sou where's the spoon why
you asking me God help
me oops I'm sorry service man with that
thank you that looks great enjoy it next
on tray is what two orat one vegetarian
or k it was great working with Gordon
tape you know we worked together we
jumped around it was good it was like a
good two man you know Vibe it felt good
you know it felt real good with Chef
Ramsey and Paul working together you got
four vegetarian I got five normal yes
four vegetarian on the way excellent
beautifully cooked fresh pasta is flying
out of the kitchen thank you very much
enjoy it there you
go oh my gosh this is so good this is
like the best pasta I've ever play stuff
your mom makes and you're in and out in
no time mhm how is it very good good
you're good I'm glad the kitchen did
everything right today that's it the
board is cleared yeah I don't have any
tickets anyone need food no food I
absolutely think lunch should be an
everyday thing at bazini I think that uh
today probably proved that to
Paul it was a great lunch service it was
really good it was profitable and we we
know we made money and uh customers were
happy and it was quick and it was easy
feel
[Music]
good
coming up it's relaunch night at bazini
this is the most important night of this
guy's life will Paul rise to the
occasion roll or really go back to his
old ways I'm one person with two hands
giving excuse don't have eyes in the
back of my head I'm doing 400 things at
once after excuse I can't cook and
manage hey we're all working together
here quit the arguing the survival of
the restaurant is on the line we're
sinking like the Titanic in here but not
everybody believes in Saving it where's
my where the [__] is you don't know he's
gone ow
[Music]
ow inspired by Paul's performance during
lunch and his fresh pasta Chef Ramsey
and his team work overnight to renovate
the
[Music]
restaurant morning hey welcome to the
new pan oh
my wow look at it new tring new song
mind it looks inviting it's gorgeous the
neighborhood with 60 restaurants you
have to stand out it looks spectacular
awesome trus just looks beautiful ready
to go inside yes let's go I have ants in
my
pants oh look at this the tables are
gorgeous I love these look at that that
was so nice gone is a lemon pound cake
on the walls new slick Italian Bonet
isn't that lovely it's just modern it
looks great the color is contemporary
look at the napkins fresh pasta made
daily welcome to B this is freaking
awesome the dining room is beautiful I
never thought in a million years this
could happen and um we are so grateful
thank you again you oh good my darling
I'm glad you're
happy the restaurant renovation was
drastic but the biggest change to bazini
is the menu Chef Ramsey has taken the
old risotto the disgusting chicken and
the Bland tilapia and replace them with
a new and vibrant menu featuring fresh
pasta love the menu from 27 dishes down
to 15 why is it reduced because it's
fast the idea is everything's cooked to
water it's fresh CH grilled calamari
with fresh chili and arugula the main
entree is BCA fresh konata with white
beans past of the day is going to be T
Telly of muscles and clams that's the
Hallmark for is that menu manageable y
looking at the menu the bar is set at
the 10 and we need to be able to get as
high to the 10 as possible certainly
nothing less than an 8 and A2 these show
T cake look at it beautiful Sumptuous
sexy and something you want to take home
to
bed
oh take home to bed oh
boy you killing
me hello welcome you are Panera with the
new new menu and the new Decor in place
follow me please Chef Ramsey has invited
VIPs and dignitaries to show why bazini
is special even amongst the 60
restaurants in town let's see what this
new menu offers us all pastas fresh made
here on the premises today I'm going to
have the calamari SE calamari to search
off
excellent first order yes you have one
plan on calamari yes chef one toini yes
chef one Tey Al I would get the Kari
working okay want try and get a little
bit more color
tickets coming in I'm not thinking about
am I going to be able to do it I'm not
thinking about oh my God we're going to
crash it's about me pushing myself to be
the person that I am tonight Paul's
attitude couldn't be better get like
four more PLS working please and
everything in the kitchen seems to be
right on track this is table number 21
Che okay good now the first appetizers
are at the pass hey guys it's roll
here touch that I can't send out raw
calamari yeah Paul please yes it's
[__] Raw my
God make sure everything's
cool PA these tables are very important
I need a second to think oh come
on Al you got come on I need help I need
you to get in the game with me please I
I can't do it all alone Al please tell
me at palenta please tell me how palenta
I know what's on the line I know we got
dignitaries in a dining room we have to
get the job done we have to get it done
well we have to just get it done get an
order in at stable 21 guys I can't and
cook and talk and manage the tickets I
need help I'm not working alone here one
was a total disaster he got flustered I
guess and there was a lack of
communication the pressure of relaunch
night has clearly gotten to Paul his suf
Al and the rest of the kitchen staff no
we're not firing at the moment and 45
minutes in not a single entree has left
the kitchen is any so high the fres
bring it out talk to me Paul please
totally special it's only a two top yeah
but Chef I want to get the four pastas
out first I know but what I'm trying to
say to you is it's the same dish put a
four and a two top together kill two
birds of one stone position yourself
manipulate the board to your advantage
come on an hour and a half later of
course we're hungry yeah this
is I absolutely understand well I hate
to say it but 33 has been waiting for
forever and I mean they're one of the
first tables that walked in this store
everything is a complete mess nobody's
getting their food the orders are all
mixed up it's just unbelievable out
there these VIP tables yeah are waiting
too long I need some help I need someone
to move tickets I can't do everything
myself need some communication we need
to [__] cook we're sinking like the
Titanic in here let's just
cook this is such a shame Paul shut down
he's not communicating and more
importantly I think he's given
up God's sake come on
po p I'm doing 400 things at once I'm
trying to do damage control at this
point damage control is not what I want
to this point I want to cook I want to
get food out I want you know clearly I
need some help 41 I need to know how
long I need someone to tell me what 41
is don't have eyes in the back of my
head okay what's our ETA on 45 Paul talk
to Al guys please stop
cooking 45 wait I still don't have an
answer I'm
41 sake this table's been waiting for an
hour can't do it all I I got this you
don't know that for sure well I I'm
waiting for like everybody here is
waiting hey don't shush me we're all
working together here we don't need a
shusher guys this is the most important
night of this guy's life quit the
arguing there he in crashed I don't know
if it's the Titanic or the Hindenburg
but it's a [__] mess all right I know
you don't want to hear this but I need a
pasta special and I need it immediately
bloody hell where's Al where's my ZF the
only one in this kitchen Al
Al where is Al I don't know where the
[__] is Al we don't know he's gone no
sign of him he's clearly gone god sakes
man
ow
[Music]
ow where is
he it's relaunch night at bazin's and
not only are customers getting restless
an hour and a half later of course we're
hungry but suf Al has gone AWOL where's
Al where's my suf
oh oh I think he quit I was shocked that
Al walked out that really sucks there
was a shock wave that went through the
kitchen the service staff no one could
really believe it come on guys please
when you just left high and dry like
that it's a little difficult listen to
me Al may be gone but the customers need
feeding let's support one another but as
a human being with compassion you go in
you help and you give it your best shot
all right take a deep breath I'm glad to
help if you cook the garnishes I can
cook the lamb the strip yes yes chef
let's go then I can only imagine what's
happening in that kitchen back there
start working on three tag two pepper
deli straight after yes chef good I'll
do the rotto Sharon so you with me I'm
totally with you Sharon congratulations
in a new Sue Chef I'm very embarrassed
our Sue Chef walked out it's not even C
it's too tight you know it's like it's
it's like stge
yeah good girl Shan thank you Chef good
girl let's go talk to me come on Paul
please I'm 1 minute from
dressing I'm 1 minute from dressing Chef
I'm working it's still going to be a few
minutes I apologize tag special in the
window good go thank you Sharon service
please to save tonight's dinner service
Chef Ramsey has taken over the kitchen
come back for the rotto please and along
with Sharon's help hold on Sharon food
is now entering the dining room asking
you shall sometimes in time receive but
now the question is do the customers
feel if it was worth the wait the food
is fantastic worth the waito has a
wonderful
taste chicken is
[Music]
delicious we had some challenges you
know we had some things that weren't
expected to happen but that said
everyone stepped up as best as they
could got good feedback from the people
so you know I feel was
success before I spend some time with
Paul and Leslie I just want to say um a
big thank you yeah your desserts are
fantastic over the desserts your
personality is for me fundamental to the
longivity and the potential success of
this restaurant and I just want to say
uh a big thank you well done I Dy yeah
oh I enjoyed his company I think he
enjoyed mine and I hope I made him proud
thank you cuz I really tried very
[Music]
hard right that wasn't easy no no
nowhere near it uh however I know the
customers love the food absolutely and
tonight confirmed that you have an
identity the fresh Pastor is out there
but truthfully as hard as this is for me
to say to you face to face honestly Paul
you haven't changed enough to convince
me that
this can turn
[Music]
around I was totally focused and totally
committed no no no no you weren't poor
Chef no no come on Big Boy the first
appetizer had raw squid not slightly
seared raw 20 minutes later the place
was sunk you needed me I regrouped got
the kitchen back together I've never
worked this hard in launching a
restaurant the truth hurts Paul you've
got to start telling yourself some
serious hope truths the way to becoming
a better Chef is to realize your
weaknesses and improve those weaknesses
I've taken all of the advice and I've
taken a lot of it to heart and I've seen
a lot of it of what I do is wrong here's
my advice at the heart of this
restaurant has to be you your food you
on the plate you have to stand up to the
plate and hold the reins I know that it
starts and stops with me and I know that
I have to be the leader and I know that
I have to command the troops I take
responsibility for that you say all the
right things always but now it's time to
do the right
things right good night thank
you I think that Chef Ramsey came in and
really identified the problems and I
think he certainly helped Paul and I
totally feel that all the tools we have
are enough to save the restaurant Chef
yes chef good luck thank you very much
appreciate everything appreciate all
your hard work and and everything youve
done for me is it's over to you now I
won't let you down this experience has
been amazing I've been put on the path
to success and I'm really excited about
going forward please don't let yourself
down thanks very much good night good
[Music]
night what a week Ridgewood may have 60
restaurants within four blocks but I do
believe the new bazas with its fresh
pasta can be a huge local success
unfortunately I'm just not sure about
Paul but nothing would make happier if
you could prove me
[Music]
wrong after Gordon's departure Paul
immediately hired a strong Sue chef and
with the new fresh pasta identity
bazin's experienced a boost in business
oh very sadly Sharon left the restaurant
to get away from Paul and to focus on
her own dessert
[Music]
business
e